l'assemblée nationale sous tension
foulée débat depuis hier sont très
tendues entre parlementaires autour du
projet de loi concernant l'extension du
pass sanitaire dans la rue les
rassemblements se poursuivre de nombreux
jeux des jouets de manifestent devant le
sénat où doit arriver le texte demain on
y retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
4 sa technique
katia bonjour vous suivez donc ce
rassemblement devant le sénat et le
passe à lithaire est toujours autant
débattu
oui absolument notre ambiance et
électriques au parlement également dans
la rue ici les environ 500 manifestants
opposés au projet de loi sanitaire qui
scande le mot liberté qui s'opposent à
la réduction des libertés individuelles
que comporterait ce projet de loi alors
les débats vont être prolongées à
l'assemblée nationale mais pourtant la
manifestation était prévue au sénat car
ici on estime que ça ne changera plus
beaucoup au niveau des amendements à
l'assemblée nationale ils veulent donc
faire pression sur les sénateurs donc
que s'est il produit aujourd'hui au
niveau des amendements entre hier et
aujourd'hui lors des débats je rappelle
tout de même que les communistes les
insoumis les socialistes s'opposent au
pass sanitaires contrairement aux
républicains qui dans leur ensemble sont
plutôt pour mais réclament des
aménagements se plaignant également une
restriction des libertés tout comme la
cnil d'ailleurs tout comme la défenseure
des droits alors le passé ni terre pour
les voyages internationaux ne sera
demandé qu aux personnes de plus de 12
ans pour les 12-17 il sera exigé à
partir de fin septembre et non plus à
partir de la fin août comme prévu et
puis autre modification pour les
visiteurs d pad d'hôpitaux et bien il
l'assemblée a voté contre le pass annie
terre aussi bien pour les patients que
les visiteurs contre l'avis du
gouvernement
pour en revenir à cette manifestation
donc des gilets jaunes sont présentes
donc voir aux contestataires ils disent
qu'ils ne sont pas forcément anti
vaccins mais contre la privation des
libertés individuelles je vous propose
d'écouter faouzi
luz gilet jaune figure du mouvement
ainsi que françois asselineau de l'upm
normalement ils sont tous élus pour
censés nous représenter
mais j'ai l'impression que toutes les 10
y est les décisions qui sont prises à
l'assemblée nationale ou au sénat vont
dans le sens des gouvernants mais pas
dans le sens de la population donc on
est là pour leur rappeler aussi que il
ya une grande majorité aussi de la
population qui n'est pas d'accord avec
ces lois liberticides qui sont votées
tout simplement donc nous je tiens à
rappeler qu'on n'est pas on n'est pas
contre le vaccin on est contre
l'obligation pour les gens de se
vacciner c'est que ce n'est pas la même
chose
celui qu'on a envie de le faire et qui
estime que c'est bien pour lui bien
qu'il le fasse mais celui qui veut pas
qu'on le laisse tranquille et on n'a pas
besoin de l'empêcher de le priver de
tags liberté de sa vie sociale est
encore plus alors là de son travail
ce que je n'arrive pas à comprendre nous
nous sommes pour le droit en france
aujourd'hui pour le droit
le pass sanitaire c'est absolument
interdits de même que la vaccination
obligatoire
ce sont des choses qui sont interdites
et donc selon le débat actuellement qui
est à l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
si de prendre des lois qui modifie les
lois existantes pour imposer justement
quelque chose qui actuellement est
interdit par exemple les discriminations
le code pénal interdit les
discriminations en fonction de l'état de
santé est bien c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
on va maintenant instaurer un système où
l'on pourra diviser les français entre
les vacciner les longues maxime est pour
le moment aucun sénateur n'est venu
débattre avec les manifestants et nous
suivons
la situation ici devant le sénat devant
lequel se sont rassemblés environ 500
personnes qui contestent le projet de
loi sanitaire et asaf ethnique devant le
sénat merci beaucoup pour tout ces
imprécisions écouter après